but nothing here too is said to be
amazing but how does it compare to the
airpods Pro 2 well today we're gonna
compare everything and see if these are
a great value especially if you have an
iPhone but to make sure we get proper
results I'll also test it with the
nothing foam now inside of the box I
really like their packaging and design
they give you this cool looking USB
type-c cable and then some different ear
tips to perfectly fit and then pulling
out the case this thing looks amazing
now it's very similar to the original
one but I can't help but just admire the
design and the look this transparent uh
case and then the earbuds themselves
where you see the board there and the
little details it is just so unique and
cool compared to the airpods Pro 2 which
we're all just used to and so many
companies just copy the design now just
like the airpods Pro 2 the design
changes are minimal but it's what's
inside that really matters and with this
case if you have a nothing phone when
you open it up it can actually see the
case and the earbuds their charge level
just like with your airpods pro now one
downside though is that the case is
quite a bit larger and thicker than the
airpods Pro 2 which is one thing that I
love about the airpods it's such a small
case you could barely tell it's in your
pocket pulling out the earbuds they have
a similar design where you have the stem
right here compared to the air pods but
the little bulb shape is a little bit
different looks a little bit smaller and
then putting it in it does feel nice and
comfortable I switch to larger tips and
one thing I love is that the controls
are pretty much identical a copy of the
airpods where you can click and then
double click and then you can press and
hold if you want to enable the noise
cancellation or the transparency mode
just like with the airpods it even has
somewhat of a similar click and here in
the app we see some details here and we
also have this menu where we have a very
similar slider to the iPhone and now
let's compare the noise cancellation I
have some airplane sound right here and
we'll see how the nothing ear twos
compare to one of the best in terms of
noise cancellation I'm going to go ahead
and play that right there definitely
allowed to turn on noise canceling
okay wow almost all of the low end went
away
I still hear quite a bit of the high end
and now for the nothing ear two
play that
okay
okay so you definitely hear more of that
airplane sound with the nothing ears now
I hear less of the high end a lot of low
ends gone too but more of that middle
kind of sound is apparent now here in
the app there's also an option called
personalized active noise cancellation
now that just ran through and listened
to the environment and it tuned it did
make it a little bit better not a huge
difference though and one interesting
thing is with these when I turn towards
my laptop the sound gets quieter but
then when I turn away it gets a little
bit louder so depending how the
microphone picks it up so overall I
would say that the airpod pros too do
take out more of that sound now Vadim go
ahead and say something hey what's up
you're definitely quieter and now with
airpods Pro Vadim say something hey
what's up man identical really so your
voice is identical I might even hear a
little bit more of the high end with
these now as far as transparency mode
let me switch it Vadim how are you doing
today pretty good man how do I sound
amazing identical airpods are so good at
this and with the nothing let's switch
over yeah pretty good you sound like
you're a little bit sick like you have a
head cold a little bit muted so it must
be the microphones and what they can
pick up now I'm guessing that's because
the microphones just aren't picking up
the high ends as well so here's a
recording from the nothing ear two and
this is the microphone quality of the
airpods pro 2. you guys let me know
which one sounds better down below now
these are 149 dollar earbuds that have
all of those features and some more
compared to 249 dollars so with that
said let's go ahead and compare the
sound quality we're gonna listen to
three songs starting out with the max
Tech classic and you guys will hear what
I'm listening to and see the difference
you're unfamiliar bring me back
[Music]
okay well the airpods are a lot louder
they have a little bit more low end bass
and the highs especially are a lot more
sharp now DMS on YouTube Compared the
frequency response and this chart shows
that Apple boosts up the highs and the
base more so than the nothing which has
a more natural true to the source sound
which is crazy now the cool thing is
they have an EQ built in unlike the
iPhone and I had that set to the default
balance mode but you can actually go in
and use a different preset or you can
customize it so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to pull the mids down
just to tie it to zero there kick up the
treble and I'm gonna kick up the bass
just a little bit and now I did some
listening and they do sound better to my
preference they sound very similar to
the airpods Pro 2 the highs are not as
sharp but they're smooth they sound
excellent it's a great sounding sound uh
just not as loud so with that tuning
let's go ahead and switch to our next
track classic by Joakim
[Music]
thank you
all right well for that one I turned the
airpods down a bit so they wouldn't be
as loud so it would match up and I'm
shocked by how close the nothing ear to
sound to the airpods Pro 2 which even
audio files like these now now I win and
I tuned The Equalizer in this case it
actually had a little bit too much bass
more bass than the air pods I actually
prefer the mids on here some of the
instruments came out better but for the
highs the airpods are a little bit more
sharp which I like I'm just really
surprised by how close they sound other
than the volume difference and for our
last song we have a rock track that has
a ton of instruments that are mixed
together and this is great for testing
out driver performance
[Music]
foreign
well I can't believe I'm gonna say this
but nothing ear 2 sounded better in this
track than the airpods Pro 2 and I love
how good these sound I am absolutely
shocked right now
um basically the airpods do have a
better Sound Stage
um and that's without this the
spatialized audio turned on but these
sounded better in the mids I heard more
separation between some of the
instruments and it sound a little bit
smoother and I'm absolutely shocked now
I could go into the app and then I can
go in and I can turn up the treble if I
wanted a little bit more
um but wow for 149 I am very impressed
now in the easier songs these sounded
better uh very close though
but all the headphones that I've
compared that are roughly 150 bucks
don't stand a chance compared to airpods
Pro 2. these actually do in terms of
sound quality the only thing is they
don't get as loud so what I'm gonna do
now is I'm going to pair them to my
iPhone because sometimes earbuds pair to
an iPhone will play louder alright well
it did Play Slightly louder not that big
of a difference though in the sound
quality still sounds very good it's not
a big difference between it
um I am just very impressed I'm glad we
test three different styles of tracks
because these drivers are performing
really really well with this difficult
song so overall
um it's very impressive now noise
cancellation not as good but still quite
good in transparency mode not as good
but what is as good as airpods but the
sound quality I am just very thoroughly
impressed and this is a big upgrade
compared to the original so good job
nothing and if you're out there use
Android or even if you use iPhone and
you're looking for an alternative
this is a great alternative it has a ton
of different features and has a lower
price and they're very unique as well if
you guys want me to test these out more
with the iPhone Everyday Use how it
works let me know down in the comment
section below if you'd be interested in
a video about that but overall great
product go ahead and click that Circle
above to subscribe check out one of
those videos right over there that's
been Max and I'll see you in the next
one
[Music]
thank you